on les a vu déambuler tout l'été
smartphone à la main ou cotiser par leur
écran dans les parcs en pleine rue au
pied d'une cathédrale absorbé fasciné
par ce qu'ils défilaient sur leur
téléphone moi ils m'ont surtout intrigué
notamment lorsque j'ai compris que ce
qui les captive et était un simple jeu
sorti au milieu de l'été
pokémon go
[Musique]
si je voulais comprendre le phénomène
pokémon go et langon qu'il a suscité
tout l'été mais fallait que je me lance
alors j'ai télécharger le jeu sur mon
téléphone est sur ma tablette puis je me
suis créé un avatar je vais aller voir
quelques dresseur je pense qu'il est une
chasse se prépare bonsoir c'est tous des
chasseurs vous m'expliquer en deux mots
le principe de pokémon go moi c'est
simple c'est d'attraper en fait tous les
pokémon qui se trouvent dans la rue on
lance une pokéball et à ce moment là le
pokémon ont la trappe où on n'attrape
pas et là on va en attraper quelques
ébats on peut aller on peut aller voir
ça vous dit c'est parti
la première des règles quand on veut
attraper des pokémon ces deux marchés
est la deuxième de maîtriser le
vocabulaire très spéciale du jeu tu
prends un programme eau électrique et
que tu sais de l'éclair sur un caillou
par exemple
pokémon go c'est un univers à part
coincé entre le réel et le virtuel où
les joueurs sont attelés driss heures et
les parties des chasses pour tenir des
soirées entières le smartphone est
indispensable le chargeur de batterie
est essentielle pour moi c'est vraiment
l'histoire de dédé avec mes compatriotes
à se brancher avec moi en fait j'ai
trois ports et ça va c'est une charge
très rapide sortie le 24 juillet dernier
en france le jeu a fait sensation
25 millions d'utilisateurs dans le monde
chaque jour des milliers de joueurs en
centre val de loire et pour tous un seul
et même objectif capturer les 142
créatures colorées qui apparaissent au
fur et à mesure de leur déambulation ces
cadavres
c'est une bonne prise pourquoi parce que
j'avais pas sur mon pokédex dans mon
projet d'aix donc du coup ça me fait à
nouveau pokémon et comme le glissait
tous les attraper là c'est une bonne
pioche à bourges
jérémy ses amis ont commencé à jouer un
peu avant la sortie officielle du jeu en
téléchargeant l'application en version
américaine
tout l'été ils ont sillonné la ville en
petits groupes
après le travail et pendant de longues
heures on essaie d'aller dans des coins
sympas et du coup c'est vrai qu'on se
rend pas forcément compte que le temps
passe au final c'est des amis qui y ait
eu son récit et jusqu'au petit matin
pour vraiment faire des tours complets
avoir des pokémon en masse à la fin de
cette virée nocturne
je réalise que le jeu attire toutes les
tranches d'âge et surtout les 20 30 ans
cette génération pokémon bercée par la
culture manga des années 90 les adultes
hyper connectés grâce auquel le jeu a
explosé je pense qu'on peut proposer ça
dimanche la faire un premier groupe en
fait l'après midi donc un premier tour
vers 14h du val d'auron et puis en
soirée peut-être vers 20h 20h30
proposait un autre groupe mais celui-ci
nocturne chasseurs la nuit modérateur le
jour richard et j'ai les miens ce sont
les créateurs du groupe pokémon go de
bourges sur les réseaux sociaux
un lieu où le jeu prend une autre
dimension et où les dresseurs intègre
une communauté je pense qu'ils l'ont
fait exprès en fait de faire sortir les
gens pour justement que ça rapproche les
joueurs entre eux parce que c'est vrai
qu'à l'heure actuelle on ad on a des
joueurs en ligne et il suffit pas
forcément d'aller à la rencontre du
joueur on est chez nous on est assis on
peut discuter avec lui peut jouer avec
lui mais on ne peut pas forcément
rencontrer là sur ce jeu là si on a des
coups intéressants des endroits
intéressants voilées ou chasser on est
obligé d'aller un peu la rencontre des
joueurs des astuces et des mises à jour
sur cette page 1300 membres partagent
leurs informations et s'entraident
derrière leur écran
les deux amis font le tri et contrôler
les publications bénévolement et par
amour du jeu une satisfaction
personnelle d'avoir réussi à réunir
autant de joueurs sous la même bannière
une bannière que nous avons créé ces
flatteurs finalement et puis mais on a
réussi à faire des rencontres on a
rencontré des gens formidables qui
partagent les mêmes valeurs que nous et
c est important c'est ce n'était pas du
tout prévu à la base mais on s'est
finalement fait des amis grassin
après un peu de temps passé avec les
joueurs je me suis rendu au château de
valençay
ici le phénomène pokémon go s'est fait
une place un peu par hasard au milieu
des vieilles pierres
[Musique]
en fait on a découvert qu'il y avait
plein de gens qui venaient pour les
pokémon puisqu'on a environ une
vingtaine de pokerstop qui sont
dispersés dans le parc dans la cour
d'honneur mais aussi dans tout le
domaine et on a trois arènes donc les
joueurs peuvent venir combattre et
gagner des points au sein du parc du
château de valençay dépôts qui stoppe et
des arènes deux éléments indispensables
aux joueurs pour évoluer dans pokémon go
ici impossible de savoir combien de
visiteurs sont venus exclusivement pour
le jeu en tout cas ils ont dû débourser
12 euros 50 pour accéder au monument un
vaste terrain de jeu où l'on a pris les
choses avec le sourire
c'est une manière comme une autre de
venir dans un lieu de patrimoine
pourquoi pas sont bien obligés de
marcher en regardant autour d'eux et je
pense que peut-être le château balance
est aussi un printemps un prétexte en
même temps si on va aller au château
valence et en plus y'a des pokémon ou l'
inverse
on va aller chercher les pokémon et au
château de valençay y en a donc en même
temps on sera dans un site agréable à
châteauroux aussi on a très vite mesuré
l'ampleur du phénomène il sautait sur
l'occasion donc entouré de la gare on va
avoir un
1 2 3 4 jusqu'à cinq fautes et stoppe
les poké stop
ce sont des points d'intérêt ou les
joueurs font le plein d'accessoires pour
leur chasse des sites référencent
épargne antique
le créateur du jeu à châteauroux il y en
a 90 7 au total
et il se trouve que nous avons un projet
stop juste là qui est assez intéressant
puisque figurez vous qu'il s'agit de
l'ancienne chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de châteauroux alors
aujourd'hui elle est effectivement si tu
es un petit peu plus loin donc ici ça a
été la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie jusqu'en 1935 pour surfer
sur la tendance
la ville a créé une carte une poké map
destiné aux touristes qui sommeille en
chaque joueur de pokémon go derrière
chaque cercle bleu un petit texte qui
résume l'intérêt patrimonial ou
culturelle du site
on pensait bien que ça aurait du succès
à un tel point en tout cas en ce qui
concerne l'office de tourisme ça a été
une agréable surprise de voir
effectivement que que la carte portait
ses fruits et permettait aux gens à la
fois effectivement de profiter au
maximum du jeu en trouvant le plus de
points le plus rapidement possible et en
même temps de redécouvrir la ville de
façon un petit peu ludique hasard de la
cartographie des restaurants et des
entreprises figurent aussi dans les po
qui stoppe une aubaine là encore pour la
ville on s'est dit que c'était pas un
problème au contraire qu'on allait
l'utiliser pour mettre en avant nos
entreprises locales
nos commerces à châteauroux est bon dans
ce cas-là descriptif on expliqué
la raison de l'entreprise ou du commerce
et mettre un lien vers leur site
internet ou leur page facebook
ses manières de les mettre en avant et
leur faire un peu de publicité
changement de décor et petit bond en
arrière je troque le téléphone pour une
vieille manette de console car pokémon
goisbault révolutionné le jeu vidéo qui
nous replonge surtout dans un univers
familier il faut laisser trompe on doigt
sur le bouton jaune si tu veux accélérer
tu freines avec le bouton vert l écart à
passer les peaux de banane c'est sur le
bouton rouge et bah ce jeu là c'est le
tout premier celui ci à 25 ans à peu
près c'est le tout premier mario kart
qu'est sortiez mario comme pikachu sonic
ce sont des stars internationales des
personnages qui font vendre et
l'industrie du jeu l'a bien compris elle
use et abuse de leur renommée chaque
année pour sortir de nouveaux produits à
leur effigie
d'ailleurs chez nintendo on entretient
la flamme pokémon depuis les années 90
d'abord grâce à des jeux sur game boy
puis grâce au dessin animé du même nom
au succès planétaire
je trouve qu'ils ont créé une très bonne
application qui est très intelligente
très simple très intuitive très bien
fait
en plus avec gratuite très bonne
stratégie commerciale déjà les gens qui
ont la première console nintendo en
général ça c'est toujours les nintendo
qui sortent depuis qu'ils prennent
toujours les mêmes personnages et cetera
et voilà le la personne qui avait
pikachu quand il avait 5 ans va le
retrouver avec pokémon go donc les mêmes
sensations
retrouver les sensations de l'enfance
une véritable passion pour clément
collectionneurs de jeux vidéo anciens
depuis douze ans chez lui on trouve des
milliers d'objets glané au petit matin
sur des brocantes très rare pour
certains alors c'est nintendo 64 édition
limitée pokémon les avait sortis
beaucoup de nintendo de toutes les
couleurs et celle ci fait partie des
plus rares parce que bahia pikachu qui
est sur la console fan inconditionnel de
la firme japonaise nintendo
clément possède des dizaines de jeux
pokémon des éditions spéciales des
peluches et des figurines et depuis le
début de l'été il l'a bien senti sa
collection fait des envieux sur le
marché de l'occasion et ça s'achète très
bien parce qu'il ya des collectionneurs
baky qui veulent se racheter le truc
qu'ils n'avaient pas avant ou un nouveau
public un peu plus jeune qui cherche à
avoir tous les pokémons les plus anciens
donc qu'ils essaient de se re procurer
les vieux et oui ça marche très bien
on ça coûte pas très cher ça coûte entre
10 15 euros maximum un jeu d'occasion
mais ça se vend très vite et très bien
parce qu'il ya du monde qui est qu'ils
recherchent
après 25 années d'existence la saga
pokémon se poursuit mais elle fascine
toujours autant que ce soit des
trentenaires nostalgiques des seniors ou
bien des familles qui ont joué ensemble
tout l'été et ce jeu a tellement séduit
qu'il a aussi provoqué quelques dérives
[Musique]
pikachu en bonne place au milieu des
jardins de bourges ont pour y croire un
simple clin d'oeil
en réalité le petit monstre jaune a fait
son apparition ici pour tenter de
préserver les pelouse et les massifs
fleuris piétiner allégrement par des
joueurs souvent distrait les pelouses
mais moi je me suis assise et dessus la
semaine dernière c'est vrai que pour
préserver l'environnement il faut il
faut mettre des messages ou et je trouve
que c'est normal
d'où ce polyglotte des jardins des
règles de bon sens et de civisme est
dictée par la ville un code de conduite
sérieux mais bienveillant pour prévenir
plutôt que guérir
on a alerté avec nos petits panneaux
d'une façon ludique on s'inquiétait un
peu du phénomène bon c'était pour
essayer de soulager un peu les espaces
un peu sur sur fréquenté au monde
on s'amuse aussi à roses et un petit peu
les certaines pelouse pour justement
dissuader nos joueurs de s'asseoir des
heures entières sur sur ce dans ce
général jardin quoi autre ville autre
parc
ici aussi la folie pokémon vous a fait
quelques dégâts au début de l'été
emplacement stratégique pour chasser le
parc de la péraudière a attiré jusqu'à
plusieurs centaines de joueurs chaque
jour et avec eux des migaud les déchets
et quelques problèmes de sécurité
conscient du problème certains ont pris
les choses en main et décidé de
travailler avec les autorités locales
résultat deux grands événements pokémon
hugo organisé en un mois sans
dégradation est en plein état d'urgence
on a coupé des routes pour la sécurité
des joueurs qui traversent un petit peu
on a installé des poubelles
supplémentaires pour gérer l'hygiène
tout ça et même nous de notre côté on a
fait de la sensibilisation où on a fait
des petites opérations nettoyage avec
nos petits sacs poubelles et ce à la
mairie s'en est rendu compte et du coup
ils sont très contents parce que nous on
à atténuer les dégâts causés aux espaces
publics et d'un autre côté on a quand
même favoriser l'arrivée de personnes
massive sur le parc
souvent critiqué pour l'heure un peu
denses dans le monde entier de nombreux
joueurs ont été impliqués dans des
accidents parfois graves cet été mais
aujourd'hui la situation s'est largement
apaisée sûrement aussi parce que le
nombre d'utilisateurs diminue chaque
jour
la fin du phénomène est peut-être proche
mais pokemon go a déjà révolutionné
l'univers du jeu sur mobile
quand il ya le nouvel iphone qui sort il
faut que ça me saoule sorte un nouveau
téléphone ou acheter ce soit à nouveau
téléphone ici c'est pareil je pense que
de toute façon d'autres marques vont
répliquer
parce qu'il faut le faire maintenant est
ce qu'elle est on vraiment l'ambition de
concurrencer pokémon ou d'avoir quelque
chose à l'échelle de pokémon je suis pas
sûr que ce soit réaliste
après expérimentation je comprends mieux
la déferlante pokémon go c'est
divertissant innovants et surtout
fédérateur pas étonnant que
l'application figurent parmi les plus
téléchargées de tous les temps un
triomphe inédit pour un jeu qui devra
vite se renouveler s'il veut durer bien
plus qu'un été